et on va parler du nucléaire c'est le
second débat de ce club puisque les
sénateurs examinaient cette semaine le
texte qui accélère la construction de
réacteurs nucléaires Audrey d'abord on
va faire un point avec vous sur l'état
du nucléaire en France oui alors petit
état des lieux la France compte 56
réacteurs nuclés nucléaires répartis
comme on le voit sur la carte qu'on va
vous montrer une carte de l'Institut de
sûreté nucléaire on a donc entre autres
quatre réacteurs au Tricastin
quatre-rachinons deux à Flamanville dans
la Manche on le sait puisque le
troisième réacteur qui doit être un EPM
de nouvelles génération accumule les
déboires techniques sont démarrage
commercial à plus de 12 ans de retard il
est désormais repoussé à mi-2024 alors
je vous ai dit 56 réacteurs ça c'est sur
le papier car dans les faits c'est plus
compliqué il y en a toujours un certain
nombre à l'arrêt c'est normal ce sont
des opérations de maintenance il y a
aussi les visites décennales plus
longues parce que le parc date
généralement du début des années 80 à
cela s'ajoute des problèmes de corrosion
inattendu ceci résultat cet été le
nombre de réacteurs ont été débranchés
sur 56 situations qui semble être
revenue à la normale il y a une semelle
il n'y en avait plus que 12 à l'arrêt
mais ce n'est pas tout il y a aussi la
question du manque de main d'oeuvre on
manque de bras dans le secteur 220
000 personnes travaillent actuellement
dans le nucléaire il en faudrait 300000
d'ici 2030 si on veut multiplier le
nombre de pair on manque aussi de
compétences un exemple je vous ai parlé
des problèmes de corrosion EDF a dû
faire venir ces derniers mois des
soudeurs du Canada et des États-Unis
pour résoudre ses problèmes l'état des
lieux papa franchement réjouissant
comment on explique Hervé Machenaud cet
état des lieux sur la filière nucléaire
aujourd'hui dans notre pays il y a deux
aspects il y a un aspect mécanique qui
est le fait que on n'a pas construit de
réacteurs nucléaires depuis les années
80 la fin des années 90 et que donc
l'industrie c'est démobilisé on ne
maintient pas une industrie sans
activité elle s'est même déplacée dans
d'autres pays la deuxième chose c'est
l'environnement politique qui a été
celui de en France pendant ces 30 ans là
30 ans pendant ces 40 ans là depuis
l'arrivée de François Mitterrand au
pouvoir on a été de réutiliser le mot de
régression en régression dans la vision
du programme nucléaire français donc
droite et gauche confond du
politiquement parlant avec plus ou moins
de plus ou moins dans plus ou moins
d'enthousiasme
suivant que c'était la droite ou la
gauche mais le résultat était le même le
président Chirac et le président Sarkozy
ont eu communiste de l'énergie qui était
aussi le ministre de l'Environnement des
écologistes notoires anti-nucléaire et
donc on est dans un système qui a
démobilisé pour ne pas dire des Molly la
filière nucléaire et le résultat est
celui qu'on dit maintenant je voudrais
faire peut-être une petite correction
par rapport à ce que vous avez dit la
durée des des arrêts de tranche
le vocabulaire utilisé
actuelle qui est effectivement beaucoup
plus longue que celle
couramment jusqu'à maintenant c'est
parce que les quatrième décennales qui
sont celles qu'on sont en qui ont
commencé sont des décennales dans lequel
on ajoute énormément de modifications
liées à une amélioration considérable de
la sûreté on veut faire passer les
centrales de ce qu'on appelait la
génération 2 c'est-à-dire la conception
originale vers le référentiel de sûreté
des centrales de génération 3
c'est-à-dire avec la prise en compte des
accidents graves et ceci conduit à des à
des modifications et des mesures
extrêmement lourdes qui conduisent à cet
allure j'ajoute que à l'occasion de ces
4e décennales on introduit aussi le les
comment dire je les conséquences de
Fukushima s'occupent les mesures post
Fukushima qui sont aussi des travaux
considérables ceci ajouté à le problème
du covid est donc la désorganisation des
arrêts de tranche pendant cette période
conduit à un certain une certaine
désorganisation
à dire responsabilité politique droite
et gauche confondues
qui a signé le l'autorisation de
chantier du dernier réacteur nucléaire
traditionnel si beau et donc bon le en
fait c'est le programme Messmer Pompidou
Giscard qui a été appliqué jusqu'en 94
ensuite
il y a eu une véritable interrogation et
l'orientation que le président
Mitterrand avait soutenu d'ailleurs de
rechercher une solution franco-allemande
c'était le symbole de la construction
européenne et de l'alliance de ces deux
grands pays industriels sauf que les
Allemands ont se sont retirés
définitivement du nucléaire et nous ont
laissé sur les bras un EPR de qui sur le
plan technologique et
grande qualité mais d'une très grande
complexité et qui ne correspondait pas
nécessairement à ce corps effet un
industriel
prestataire de service comme EDF qui
aurait pu très simplement prolonger
les générations antérieures en faisant
évoluer des réacteurs qui étaient
parfaitement maîtrisés et qui entre 900
et 1200 mégawatts correspondaient
parfaitement aux besoins français nous
avons voulu faire une
performance et cette performance a été
d'autant plus compliqué à mettre en
oeuvre alors ça c'est un point qui est
important de souligner c'est que le
contrôle c'est plutôt une bonne chose
pour les pour les citoyens le contrôle
de l'industrie en général et de
l'industrie nucléaire en particulier
beaucoup plus exigeant aujourd'hui vous
avez cité l'IRSN c'est surtout la SN qui
prend les décisions mais dans les deux
cas nous avons aujourd'hui une
transparence sur le risque nucléaire qui
n'existait peut-être pas au moment du
grand élan
du programme
Messmer mais c'est plutôt une sécurité
est-ce qu'il est dû selon vous de
mauvais choix politiques il y a eu des
je le pense profondément je pense qu'il
y a eu des concessions faites à des gens
qui ont des seins qui ont des
convictions ils ont le droit de les
avoir conviction très anti-nucléaires et
qui se sont fondés sur sur une illusion
c'est la stagnation de la consommation
électrique on s'aperçoit que la des
carbonation de du monde c'est une
volonté qui je crois assez largement
partagée que ce soit sur le transport
sur l'industrie sur le chauffage y
compris des particuliers passera plus
naturellement indépendamment de la
décarbonation le développement du
numérique avec une consommation que le
numérique entraîne
ipso facto et considérable relance
complètement le besoin d'électricité
alors que depuis les de l'environnement
de l'excès en Borlo on était parti à une
sur l'idée qu'on pouvait stabiliser les
choses qui étaient une erreur manifeste
on va laisser Nicolas répondre sur les
choix politiques la question des choix
politiques est-ce qu'il y a eu de
mauvais choix politiques qui ont conduit
aujourd'hui la filière nucléaire est
dans cet état en tout cas il faut il
faut essayer de se projeter sur l'avenir
parce que ce qu'on a vu quand même là
sur les derniers mois c'est qu'on était
dans une impasse peut-être quand même
rétablir un élément factuel le mix
énergétique ou plus exactement la
répartition de la production énergétique
en France sur ce qu'on appelle l'énergie
primaire elle est quand même je parle
pas de l'électricité en énergie primaire
de manière globale sur l'électricité
c'est encore plus elle est quand même
aujourd'hui en France de 40% sur le
nucléaire donc le nucléaire reste en
France principal l'énergie principale
puis ensuite vous avez ça pose d'autres
questions on le voit avec l'Ukraine le
pétrole le gaz et seulement seulement
14% d'énergie renouvelables et sur
l'électricité si je dis pas de bêtises
la part nucléaire doit être autour de
60% 90% quelque chose comme ça donc on
reste un pays où le nucléaire a une part
prépondérant la difficulté dans laquelle
on est aujourd'hui c'est que un certain
nombre d'enjeux de maintenance de mise à
jour enfin ce qui vient d'être dit non
pas été suffisamment anticipé alors si
on essaye de regarder les choses avec le
l'intérêt général en ligne de mire
d'abord quand même il faut toujours
appeler je dis d'une phrase il faut
quand même le dire la première énergie
renouvelable c'est celle qu'on consomme
pas parce qu'on fait toujours beaucoup
l'accent sur la production enfin le
premier sujet c'est la sobriété au sens
de l'isolation des bâtiments très fort
non mais c'est bien le problème moi je
suis à Rouen vous avez tant et tant mais
vous connaissez Rouen tant étant de
passoire thermique vous avez beaucoup de
logements notamment sociaux qui sont
donc évidemment qu'on consomme plus
bêtement puisqu'on se met à chauffer
l'ère de la rue quoi pour le dire
rapidement mais c'est un autre sujet
mais enfin il est quand même très lié à
l'âge de café mais il est quand même
très lié à la question de la production
ensuite la France a un très gros retard
sur les énergies renouvelables je
rappelle quand même que la France est
condamnée pour son inaction en la
matière on en a pas besoin ah ça je ne
suis pas d'accord avec vous
on va revenir précisément sur la filière
nucléaire et les formations
le besoin en électricité il est et on le
constate dans cette période
l'augmentation un problème de
production à la pointe et c'est parce
que on manquait de gaz et de nucléaire à
la pointe que on est dans cette
situation de crise c'est pas parce qu'on
manque d'énergie renouvelable il y a 250
gigawatts d'éolien en Europe
c'est-à-dire quand il y a du vent comme
ça a été le cas à partir du 20 décembre
on est inondé et les prix de
l'électricité tombent à 0 ou en dessous
de zéro et donc rajouter et quand il y a
pas de vent ce qui était le cas le 8
décembre on importe l'Allemagne de
l'électricité au charbon à 500 euros le
mégawattheure c'est-à-dire que quand il
y a du vent il y en a trop on en ait
submergé par le vent quand il y a pas de
vent on en a pas assez et ça sert et
donc rajouter un seul gigawatt d'éolien
en France est absurde
c'est un problème de pointe les moyens
et en Europe la pointe c'est toujours
l'hiver le soir
généralement quand il fait froid il y a
une autre pression sur l'Europe il y a
pas de foisonnement en Europe et par
conséquent les moyens de produire de
l'électricité pilotable en Europe c'est
de l'hydraulique du charbon du gaz et du
nucléaire il faut choisir entre ces
trois-là le renouvelable ne sert qu'à se
substituer éventuellement au combustible
fossile pour faire des économies de CO2
en France on n'a pas on n'a pas de
production fossiles on a donc pas besoin
de de renouvelable et donc rajouter du
renouvelable en France c'est un poids
économique qui au contraire de ce qui se
passe en Allemagne
réduit la production nucléaire et comme
il réduit la production nucléaire et
qu'en gros le coût du nucléaire est
constant et fixe ça augmente le coût de
la production
parce que du coup il y a eu un virage
politique de la part d'Emmanuel Macron
qui veut relancer la filière nucléaire
sauf que pour relancer la filière
nucléaire Audrey l'a dit à des problèmes
de formation il faut donc former
Jonathan du Priest va nous amener au
cœur de ces formations on regarde
sur les bords de Loire la centrale
nucléaire de Chinon au pied de l'édifice
sont installés de nombreux industriels
du secteur comme Endel une filiale du
groupe de BTP Altrad l'entreprise
sous-traitant d'EDF pour la maintenance
des centrales possède ici une école pour
former ses futurs salariés dont Valentin
25 ans essaye de toujours quand il
démonte
de poser des pièces dans l'ordre que tu
démontré après le covid le jeune homme
graphiste de formation a décidé de se
réorienter vers la robinetterie
industrielle l'aspect manuel du métier
la séduit le côté méthodique
organisation
ce côté-là manuel que j'ai toujours eu
mais que j'avais un peu délaissé avec
mes études cette profession méconnue à
laquelle il se forme et pourtant clé
dans les centrales en plus d'être très
recherchés
si je me trompe pas ça doit être à peu
près 80% de tout ce qu'on retrouve dans
une centrale c'est une voix qui est très
porteuse et le métier est très
intéressant quand on veut faire
correctement les choses le nucléaire
nous emmène à faire justement les choses
bien comme Valentin plusieurs centaines
de personnes passent chaque année dans
cette école spécialisée dans les métiers
de la métallurgie du nucléaire des
formations tuyauterie chaudronnerie ou
soudage financé principalement par
l'industriel mais aussi subventionné par
l'État à hauteur de 2 millions d'euros
issus du plan de relance l'an dernier on
avait 600 personnes qui ont été formées
au titre de au sein de l'école des
métiers donc à la fois du salariés endl
et les salariés quelques salariés
extérieurs et nos clients également et
ça représente à peu près 60 000 heures
de formation donc quand même quelque
chose de conséquent formé des talents et
les garder dans le giron du nucléaire
sera l'enjeu majeur des prochaines
années pour un secteur longtemps décrié
par l'opinion et délaissée par les
décideurs politiques les dernières
centrales ont été construites dans les
années 80
plus de gros programme industriels
depuis qui fait que aujourd'hui on a
reconstruire la totalité d'une filière
nucléaire au regard des enjeux qui
arrivent le nucléaire étant passe de
trouver un nouveau souffle Emmanuel
Macron a annoncé la création de 14
nouveaux réacteurs pour atteindre les
objectifs climatiques back carbone face
à ses besoins le nucléaire va devoir
recruter massivement le gifen syndicat
des industries du secteur estiment
aujourd'hui les besoins en recrutement
entre 10 à 15000 postes par an sur les
10 prochaines années dont 4000
ingénieurs certains sortiront
probablement de cette classe donc là
vous êtes où
à Paris Emmanuel Galichet forme des
étudiants de Master 1 en génie nucléaire
au menu ce jour-là visite d'une centrale
en réalité virtuelle les jeunes en
général ils sont pas allés sur une
centrale nucléaire donc grâce à la
réalité virtuelle
vont à nucléaire
incroyable parce qu'on il y a peu de
personnes finalement qui peuvent rentrer
dans les bâtiments réacteurs et les
futurs professionnels sont plutôt
réceptifs à cet exercice pratique teinté
de haute technologie c'est une très
bonne chose qu'on ait pu faire cette
réalité virtuelle en plus j'en ai jamais
fait aussi donc j'ai vu pas mal de
choses donc tout ce qu'on trouve dans
une centrale une cuve le pont le pont de
commande le pompe polaire etc on a la
chance de passer du 2D à la 3D de
pouvoir se balader et surtout de se
rendre compte en fait de de l'Intérieur
voilà de l'intérieur d'une centrale de
qu'on puisse avoir une image réelle dans
cette classe les élèves sont en
apprentissage et travail déjà en
entreprise tous sont destinés à occuper
des métiers aujourd'hui en tension sur
le terrain chez EDF ou Orano en bureau
d'études ou encore chez un sous-traitant
ils auront un job avant même leur
diplôme j'ai à peu près 100%
d'employabilité à la fin de la formation
ils sont presque tous ils ont ils ont
presque tous un poste avant diplômés les
entreprises se les arrachent évidemment
parce qu'ils ont grâce à l'apprentissage
ils ont vraiment un côté opérationnel
que les formations initiales sont statut
étudiant au moins si l'industrie du
nucléaire semble se réorganiser pour
rebondir un problème se dresse sur sa
route certaines branches métiers font
face à une pénurie de formateurs au
risque de voir disparaître des
compétences sur lesquelles la France
avait pourtant beaucoup investi par le
passé
est-ce que la durée de formation et la
pénurie qui a actuellement est
compatible avec le calendrier premier
par Emmanuel Macron le calendrier dans
les années 70 on a décidé au moment de
la crise du pétrole un grand programme
nucléaire moins de 7 ans après on
sortait Fessenheim et ensuite quatre
réacteurs par an en moyenne et dans les
10 premières années on a construit 40
réacteurs dire qu'en 2020 la France ne
serait pas capable de le faire c'est un
parti pris politique la la réalité c'est
que pour que
se développe il faut qu'elle ait une
visibilité et un programme en 1970 on a
dit on va construire un grand programme
nucléaire national il faut dire la même
chose aujourd'hui parce que le nucléaire
est une industrie qui est très coûteuse
du fait de la qualité et de la sûreté et
par conséquent les investissements sont
considérables en investit pas pour
construire un réacteur même si un
réacteur on construit ici on a une
perspective industrielle et d'ailleurs
c'est vraisemblablement le vrai vecteur
de réindustrialisation de la France et
donc il faut commencer par afficher une
véritable volonté politique pour un
véritable programme pour arriver à ce
qu'on avait obtenu dans les années 80
une capacité de produire de
l'électricité en France abondante
économique sur et stable dans la durée
pendant avec 80% de nucléaires juste un
mot la raison pour laquelle la majorité
sénatoriale dans le texte qu'elle vient
d'adopter sur l'accélération des
procédures administratif pour la
construction des centrales nucléaires à
fixer des objectifs quantitatifs qui
n'avaient rien à voir avec le projet de
loi je le reconnais volontiers pour
montrer très clairement que le débat
était ouvert et qu'il y avait des
perspectives importantes de construction
de centrales nucléaires la réponse sera
donnée par la loi qui établira la
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
mais au moins le débat est ouvert et
nous avons fixé des objectifs mais sur
les objectifs par rapport à ce que peut
faire à l'heure actuelle la filière
Nicolas mayor Rossignol et est-ce que ce
que dit Emmanuel Macron c'est-à-dire une
première coulée de béton avant la fin de
son quinquennat et EDF qui vise une mise
en service de le père de penlis chez
vous dans votre département 2038 ça vous
paraît réaliste en tout cas ça me paraît
nécessaire moi je dis très clairement
n'est pas en désaccord sur ce point il
faut un mix énergétique et sur la
filière on a besoin de prévisibilité on
a besoin d'un programme industriel qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas clair n'est pas
suffisamment d'envergure notamment et je
mettrai l'accent sur les sites existants
vous avez cités Dieppe je pourrais vous
citer Gravelines évidemment et où vous
avez besoin
d'investissement et de prévisibilité sur
du long terme et même du très long terme
et il faut le faire tout de suite parce
qu'on voit bien que on se retrouve sinon
dans des situations ça je partage
complètement des situations de rupture
là où peut-être on a un point de nuance
ou de désaccord c'est que je dis que en
même temps si j'ose dire on est aussi en
retard à d'autres pays on fait ce choix
là sur les énergies renouvelables et
qu'on peut pas en faire l'économie à mon
avis pour d'autres raisons pour d'autres
raisons qui ont très à la décarbonation
avec le nucléaire on a aussi de la
décarbonation et aussi à des
développements industriels qui sont
intéressants et qui sont fait aussi dans
d'autres pays alors évidemment ça pose
la question du stockage ça pose la
question d'intermittence vous avez tout
à fait raison mais là où je pense qu'on
se retrouvera c'est qu'on a un vrai
projet de réindustrialisation la France
et de souveraineté autour de cet enjeu
énergétique
le fiasco de Flamanville puisque là on
peut parler de fiasco pèse sur la
filière politiquement ça pèse
Flamanville tourne et les problèmes sont
liés dans la dialectique entre
l'industriel et le contrôleur qu'est-ce
que je pourrais dire un mot sur le père
de Flamanville
le problème de l'EPR c'est que
EDF la France avait un programme
industriel de réacteur qui était une
évolution permanente en amélioration
constante et puis il y a une rupture
pour une décision politique et le
nouveau réacteur alors qu'on était en
train d'étudier ce qu'on appelait le
rept 2000 ou le N4 plus l'évolution
classique on a on a arrêté et on a fait
quelque chose de entièrement nouveau
dans des conditions très difficiles où
il fallait se mettre d'accord avec les
autorités de sûreté allemande et si
mince qui avait des enjeux et des
objectifs politiques et commerciaux que
que la France n'avait pas et donc on est
dans une rupture industrielle dans on a
construit quelque chose qui est
extraordinairement complexe très
difficile à construire pour ne pas dire
on le voit extrêmement difficile à
construire merci merci beaucoup le temps
prêt j'espère qu'on aura l'occasion de
refaire un débat avec vous sur ce du
nucléaire ce sera avec grand plaisir
merci beaucoup d'être venu Hervé mashnot
je remonte votre livre la France dans le
noir
on refera un débat entre vous trois je
vous Je vous remonte la
France
[Musique]